so I would attained serious claim for
example and explain death's murder
series sexual crimes so in my role I
span everything from crime scene right
through to court however there were some
people who concentrate on crime scene
only in some people who are lab-based
and it really depends on what your role
is and the crying type you're working on
in our organization we also do
ballistics which is investigation of
firearms we do chemistry which looks
into fires tool marks Footwear marks
there's also document and handwriting
there's forensic science behind
controlled drugs and toxicology drug
driving drink driving so it's a massive
massive area
forensic basically means for the court
so you'd apply in science to the court
and biology is my area of science but
there's lots of other areas of science
that are equally as applicable just a
different kind of case study